we flew him all the way from Las Vegas
Nevada after his big win and Dana
White's Contender series he is the
biggest UFC Prospect of all time it's
Beau nickel on this week's food truck
Diaries and I'm feeding them grilled
cheese let's go
[Music]
I need everything I get super thick boy
used to have a model [ __ ] now I got a
thick one yeah I do last night went late
yeah we had a sick one yeah very drunk
yeah and I like so there's a hurricane
right there's a hurricane in Florida and
it's really messing up all the travel
all over the United States so our friend
Bo nickel is flights delayed the food
truck you don't you can't rent it for
the entire day we only have a few hours
so this flight's delayed so my thick ass
is gonna hopefully order something that
Bo's gonna want to eat today because
he's not here on time for the food truck
so that we're doing a remix this is
called it's called doing on the Fly
welcome to entertainment so I'll do my
best hopefully Bo doesn't get pissed
we'll see who would be mad out of
freaking grilled cheese come on he seems
like a good dude redhead redhead be cool
uh what's up brother how you doing I'm
good man uh what What's your most famous
uh grilled cheese here our most famous
uh we're known for our uh barbecue
pulled pork and mac and cheese grilled
cheese sandwich all right let's do this
man yeah let's do two of those two of
those
um then let's do the uh
uh I saw it on the menu there the uh the
triple cheese threat
two of those and then two of the keto
bowls with the the barbecue uh pulled
pork and then whatever else you mix in
there for the keto
oh yep hopefully eats it hope he liked
it
cheese
that's it brother that's it thank you so
much man thank you yep foreign
[Music]
my dude how you doing man awesome
awesome man the myth the legend the
biggest UFC Prospect of all time you
feel any uh pressure
no no pressure no pressure you see that
cool as a cucumber man just excited you
know very grateful to to be where I'm at
I put a lot of work in and stuff so just
you know happy to put on Great
Performances and be where I'm at yeah
you have like this calmness about you
which I think is scary if I was to fight
you right because
um I mean there's been guys in the UFC
that come in high regards or you know
like Aaron Pico who's actually coming to
fruition now where they have these you
know extensive wrestling backgrounds and
then when you see mattress like all
right Stan that's a little stiff you
know but if he gets him down this would
be good and they're far out from it
but I watched your fight last night for
those who don't know he's fresh off the
contender series after he demolishes
poor dude but he was seven and one no
punk like that guy's no punk right you
know like he's not some you know just
average dude that they're just tossing
to you like that was supposed to be a
tough test man you know and so my point
is is
and I'm not gonna out anybody here but
I'm talking people who know the game
people we all know we're taxing you're
fighting like dude name somebody you
wouldn't bet on him in the top five in
the top ten like give me the list and I
was like I got nothing for you because
when when I watch that fight and the
guy's seven and one and I see you're not
you know you'll see a lot of guys that
don't have too much experience inside
the Octagon they're like I gotta get
they're like panicking but you're out to
like moving like a box you landed the
punch and then on and tell me if I'm off
on this and I'll let you speak but on
your Wikipedia it says you're a blue
belt yeah in what world does a who's
your coach who's your coach I'm a black
man I don't know if I can promote you
right now but I'm a goddamn black belt
you are not a blue belt dude no blue
belt moves like that yeah you'd be there
in what 56 seconds 52 seconds whatever
under admit it who's counting here but
the transitions you had three different
submissions and then finally get done
with a triangle without arms without
using your hands that ain't Bluebell
dude I don't your coach is but I need to
talk to him yeah well first off shout
out to my coach Marcel Ferreira with
American top team so you know he's been
coaching me and teaching me and stuff so
I got to train a little more in the ghee
if I want to he's a old school Brazilian
dude so I gotta you know get a few
training sessions he's one of those guys
yeah he's a great dude great dude so
he's I mean I'm sure he told me I'll be
black belt within like two years or
something yeah so or next week yeah yeah
right well let's just give it to you now
you know yeah I mean I I just really
feel comfortable in any situation I
think you know obviously wrestling goes
without saying but I have great coaches
around me in Jiu Jitsu like I said and
in Striking so
um you know I put the work in put the
time in put that put all the effort in
and I think like you know you see a lot
of these dudes transitioning and it was
actually the guy that gave me the best
advice was actually my dad going into my
first amateur fight which was only a
year ago he was like you know just
he's like I'm not a pro fighter or
anything but you know I've been in a few
fights back in my day and yeah you just
gotta let your instincts take over yeah
so anytime I go into a flight that's
what I'm thinking about I'm not thinking
about doing techniques like oh I need to
work on a low kick or oh I need to try
to land a jab like I'm just thinking
about fighting and like winning the
fight just capitalize the one yeah all
the training and all the techniques that
I work and the the drills that I do they
just kind of they're going to come out I
know that because I put the time in I'm
disciplined I'm doing all the things
that other people aren't willing to do
so when the time it comes time to fight
and put on the performance I'm just
relaxed be myself let it flow yeah it
seems like the more pressure that's on
you the better you perform which is
scary again you're so calm it's alarming
you know what I'm saying like you just
have strong demeanor about you yeah and
I think too you know I was soon coming
up in that Penn State wrestling room
where it's you know top-notch top of the
spare wrestling room that's going to
prepare you especially the mental
toughness oh yeah well I think I've had
a good progression you know like I I
start I've wrestled started wrestling at
five years old you know been wrestling
live yeah I wrestled over 20 years and
uh my my dad is a wrestling coach my
grandpa is a wrestling coach uh my
grandpa wrestled in college my dad
played football in college so like
Sports and you know Athletics and
understanding that was kind of just in
my DNA and I had a nice like what I feel
at this point was like a steady incline
of pressure and and high uh pressure
situations with like youth wrestling you
know I remember being like seven eight
years old and at a tournament there
would be like 100 people crowd around my
mat just like watch me and stuff because
seven that's all yeah because I was just
killing guys like at that age and then
uh you know continuing to improve like
high school wrestling state
championships and national championships
my first International competitions when
I was like 16 17 going over to other
countries competing against Russians and
Iranians and stuff like that so then
College obviously a whole nother level
wrestling for Penn State high profile
program my freshman year in college I
was competing sold out Madison Square
Garden this one I'm like 19 you know the
NCAA finals and stuff and a regular
weekend for me was 10 000 fans and press
and all that type of stuff so you're
built for it yeah yeah I'm used to it I
know all that entails and I'm ready to
go so now you know obviously this is a
bigger step you know coming into
contenders coming to the UFC like
there's more eyes and it's a bigger
platform but I've had a nice you know
progression up to where I'm at now yeah
and I think too before I move on with
that when you were six and seven
obviously you're an outlier then what do
you think made you the outlier
because I and correct me if Iran you
know people go if it's a football player
if the basketball player you know my
son's in Jiu Jitsu my son's in
basketball baseball soccer all that
trash but you know I'll watch it the
soccer soborne but I'll watch it and
you'll see outliers like they could be
really fast or you know he's good
footwork but when it comes to wrestling
what do you think it is because I would
assume you don't run like a four four
forty oh I'm fast I don't like a four
five do you really in high school I run
a four or five I'm a good athlete people
don't know oh I'm not saying you're not
a good athlete no no no but you know
what I'm saying in those sports like
like chocolate it's a freak right you
see a kid and it's yeah you really run a
four or five yeah yeah I think I mean I
I probably could have played division
one football if I would have wanted to
and stuff but uh I think you know that
that aside as a young kid
I think I just had like a kind of a
different mental capacity relative to
other kids where like
like I said at six and seven I was I was
smashing fools and people were watching
me like I also had big goals I was like
thinking about being a state champion in
high school already and a national
champion in college and I think that had
a lot to do with my dad being a coach I
said your dad instilled that in you I
assume oh I wouldn't even say it was
like a
conscious instillment it was more like
hey he was winning state championships
with his teams and so like I want to be
like those guys and like he was you know
pouring into the sport and he was just a
good role model for me and all those
guys on the team at that point were good
Role Models so like I wanted to be like
them and I just like kind of was already
in that environment around a lot of
people that were winning and doing well
and so like literally from that age I
was like that's what I'm gonna do like I
kind of was able to think about those
types of things young and and kind of
see what these guys were doing because
like a regular day for me is like I
would get up go to school I would go uh
watch my dad's high school practice see
how they did it and then I would train
at the club after that and uh so that
was like I was just grew up in that
culture yeah it was this culture for
sure that's dope
um and wrestling at Penn State I mean
because there's been guys that have gone
from Penn State into mixed martial arts
the UFC Bellator you know you think of
uh Phil Davis right he's a stud yeah
complete freak out I've trained with
freak I freak built like a freaking you
know praying mantis yeah just this
monster yeah so you got guys like Phil
Davis had a great freaking career man
UFC and uh Bellator and then you got uh
Ruth right yeah Ruth who's Savage as
well yeah yeah he won a lot of fights in
Bellator and stuff won a lot of fights
in about door
and this isn't a knock on them Phil
Davis said buddy I Love Phil yeah I love
training with Phil I absolutely adore
Phil but when I watch early film and Ed
Ruth's fights and I watch yours there's
just something yours is different like
your movement your your calmness your
your fight IQ it's just different and I
I knew Phil was gonna be a world
champion I think he ended up being world
champion in Bellator and you know he's
always a top perennial top five guy yeah
in UFC but there's just something that
you're even though you don't have as
much experience inside the the cage
there there's just there's a little more
advanced than they are let's take a
little break from chat with my Ginger
friend we're talking about Bo nickel
baby because I'm here to tell you about
manscape finally The Summer's over we've
been sweating our tails off here in
Calabasas but it is the season when
girls are buying that pumpkin spice
latte they're doing all that stuff but
you're the Bros out there you got to
make sure you're taking care of your
crotch and you guys know I'm worried
about all your hairy noses and ears and
your wieners and listen today's food
truck is brought to you by manscape the
only company you need to know for Men's
Grooming all right join the Six Million
Bros worldwide who trusts manscape by
going to manscape.com for 20 off and
free shipping with the code shop20
that's s-e-h-aub 20. all right whether
you're brand new or already with the
crew at manscape you could use the crown
jewel of care for your family jewels I'm
talking about that Platinum package 4.0
Daddy
your hairy bush is going to dread when
it sees that lawnmower 4.0 headed
straight towards your slong because you
know it's going to give you that Philly
fade if you want it you want to you want
to do the fresh prince of Bella haircut
on your nut sack well manscape got you
covered with that lawnmower 4.0 man they
got you listen includes the lawnmower
4.0 body trimmer you get the weed
whacker nose air hair trimmer
additionally to that you get the
upgraded shower routine all sorts of fun
stuff with that you the body wash you
also get the Ultra Premium two in one
shampoo and conditioner what's up and
don't forget the house got that Ultra
Premium deodorant all right but also how
about a crop preserver ball deodorant
they got the crop reviver and also how
about they throw in two free gifts for
you you get the Platinum package 4.0 you
get those two free gifts you get the
manscape boxers and the shed travel bag
so you can put all your goodies into one
thing when you're on the road trying to
trim your trunk all right so go to
manscape time get twins off and free
shipping with the code shop20 that's
schaub20 that's 20 off with free
shipping at manscape.com when you use
code shop 20 manscape play out the
leaves it's time your tree trunks time
to shine yeah I mean obviously those
guys are guys I look up to because you
know they've competed at a high level in
wrestling in an MMA and I've had plenty
of conversations with Phil and Ed about
like you know things that they think
they'll they do they do well and you
know just advice and stuff so you know
they're obviously like I said guys I
look up to and
see in a very positive light but I just
think like for me
it's just it's it's a lot about my
mentality and what I'm trying to do in
the sport I feel like with where the
sport of MMA is right now like I have a
real chance to kind of change the entire
game in a lot of different ways meaning
well I would say
in in one way just like
the the approach approach to the sport
uh my approach to the sport is very
different than I think you know Fighters
approach typically because of the
programs that I've grown up in and like
I mean you you played in the NFL like
you know like what a a program is what
like that organization is like that's
what we have at Penn State that's what
my Dad did at a high school level at a
smaller level and so like I know what
it's like to have a success as an
individual but also like
as a as a unit as an organization and
like I want to bring that type of
mentality into MMA where like we're real
professionals more professional we're
not dudes that are just tough dudes off
the street that are rolling up here like
eating and drinking whatever and then
just like fighting it's not the tank to
have it dude no no like that's like I
wanna I mean and obviously like we're
already trending that way but I want to
take it to a whole nother level like if
you watch
if you if you listen to an interview of
anybody in the NFL or NBA MLB like the
way they talk you know they're they're
vernacular their language is complete
like when they discuss their sport
correct is super different than the way
mma's discussed correct and mma's
discussed yo he's got hands he throws
bombs oh his jiu jitsu's sick it's like
what are you really saying you're not
saying anything like listen to Cooper
cup talk about how he runs a route like
it's a completely different ball game
are you a Cooper cup fan
best player in the NFL hauler dude
Eastern Washington what are we doing bro
like he's a Savage no but I agree I
think it's trending that way and because
you're such an outlier in uh college
wrestling we've had outliers before but
just so the crews away I know your boys
know this you weren't just you know you
won the basically the Heisman trophy for
college wrestling but you were Big Ten
athlete of the year not wrestler of the
year not personally
athlete of the year so big tens Ohio
State pen all the football all the
basketball Michigan State Big Boy Sports
and you won that award yeah that's
actually you know that was really cool
for me I you know when I when I looked
at uh my goals as far as what I want
Awards I want to win and stuff like that
like you know the Hodge trophy like you
alluded to which is the Heisman for
wrestling that was like number one for
me but then when they they gave me Big
Ten athlete of the year I was like yo I
kind of went to like a new level here
like that's sick because now we're
talking all these all sports we're not
talking just wrestling and that was big
for me like I felt like that gave me a
lot of confidence because then I kind of
it opened my eyes almost like I'm like
oh like there's a bigger world out there
like I was kind of Zoom focused in
wrestling for a long time and that was
like I'm like wow like you know if
people are recognizing me as far as like
all around athlete like that's that's a
much bigger bigger world than I I want
to tap into that it not only helps you
out but it helps wrestling out in
general because wrestling for whatever
reason it still flies under the radar a
little bit yeah unless you're you know
you're into the sport which I am right
but in general like the the general
thing that flies on the radar I mean
ESPN put on you know the the final
tournament stuff like that finals but
outside that you know it flies into the
radar for sure and I think that I think
there's a lot of problems with the way
that wrestling's handled from a media
perspective from a personality
perspective it was always taught like
humble yeah but like don't be flashed
not even real humble like fake humble
yeah like you can I can tell some guys
want to be like yeah but they can't
right you got to be like you gotta like
overdo it and like over act like almost
like you're not good yeah and it's like
nobody wants to listen to that or watch
that or see that and it's like one thing
to be like humble like I do feel humble
because any person that I go out to
compete against I respect I know that
they can take my head off in a second so
I have to be humble in that way but at
the same time like I put the work in
like I'm not gonna act like I don't yeah
you're there's no and that's one of the
reasons why I'm such a big fan I don't
get a sense of Cockiness out of you I
get a sense of confidence which is
different you're talking about two
different things definitely and I think
like you know you can always take a a
line like a headline the media can
always take it and spin it any way they
want some people can yeah yeah you get
it so they can say whatever they want
about it but I know for me like in my
heart like I have humility absolutely as
a
pillar in you know the type of person I
want to be yes and so I'm going to live
that out right and but that doesn't mean
that I don't believe in myself that
doesn't believe that that doesn't mean I
don't believe I can go beat any of these
guys right now in a fight and uh I think
yeah people just kind of get that mixed
up and I think you know because you know
last night on the contender Series in
the press conference you said uh what
you call out homside
and uh maybe I'm drinking the the
freaking Kool-Aid here I'm like man I'd
love to see that I was like hell yeah I
hope they do it and then you know
everyone online's like this is
ridiculous I'm like is it though am I
crazy now Dana and and I'd love to talk
about this you know we had uh
um Laura sankon who's a huge fan of
yours and she's great she's great and I
was like this is you know I'm such a fan
of bow I wish they're just making the
king of the contender series and then he
just mops the floor they want to give
him experience and she's like but she
was like he could she was like but bran
you think about you're telling me he
won't beat someone's got in top 50 I'm
like no he would yeah you know but um
with you again it's not a cocky thing
where you'll get a kid with you know not
much background especially with your
background and the award You've Won and
the the win one fight contest is like
you know I want uh Jon Jones right now
and everyone's like okay dude good luck
and that that see that's a cocky like
false sense of confidence
again with you when you call it Hans I'm
like oh hell yeah that'd be a good fight
yeah you know and I I know you're not
doing it to make the headlines or you
legit think you can compete with those
guys yeah that's a fight I want I want
that fight so you know I think I think
it's a couple things like people as soon
as that happens everybody's gonna be
like yo you're crazy bro listen now
you're gonna get smashed like this and
it's Gotta Stay your course yeah yeah
and don't listen I don't I don't really
give a crap what they say because they
don't know anything that I've done to
get to where I am up up to this point
they don't know what it takes to be a
state champion in wrestling to be a NCAA
Champion to be a world champion like
they don't know all the hours and hours
that I put in to do those things they
don't know what I do every single day in
the training room and how committed I am
to MMA now so like and that goes for
fans media Fighters and all of them like
that people say oh it'll be different
when he gets to the big leagues wait
till he fights somebody good okay well
my first profile I fought on old guy my
second one I fought a 3-0 guy now I find
a seven one guy they're gonna keep
saying this type of stuff you're never
gonna satisfy it yeah and I don't really
care because I'm not fighting for those
no exactly yeah but I I think Dana and I
actually
I agree with him on this because you
know I've had sugar Sean here I've you
know Patty Pim with all the guys in Pico
uh said in hindsight if you could redo
it I learned the hard way in my UFC
career because I had three fights and
I've seen on six months after I'm
fighting Gonzaga number 12 in the world
like Jesus Christ by the time I was like
I'm gonna start this dude right go on
you know yeah but it's a it's a it's a
marathon it's not a Sprint right so I'm
not opposed because Daniel's like hold
up he's not finding a top two guy in the
world
although I do think you could give him a
lot of problems I'm a big believer in
that and beat most of the guys in the
top five but I'm on board with all right
all right you want to you want him to
earn that cool man toss this whoever you
want because all it does is for the
hardcores we're aware of you right yeah
all it's going to do is keep building
right building building building and I
don't know the how it is on the
contender shares with the contract I
don't know if your manager is a six is
it a six fight contract is it the same
as Ultimate Fighter do you know
similar so that contract you're not
making life-changing money you know what
I'm saying making good money but it's
not you're not going Sizzler you know
what I'm saying it's good I'm going
Sizzler you're going Sizzler well it
depends what kind of scissor you're
going I think everyone Sizzler is
different it's different I bet my
scissors different than yours oh 100 but
but all I'm saying is let's say 3-0 I'm
going Sizzler yes yeah yeah for three
notes you're you're eating flaming young
it says like 3-0 yeah you're making way
more money but all I'm saying is it's
not a bad plan to just build that resume
and then when you get to that stage
where you're fighting the homs lots and
the rest of the the izzies and those and
the Apollo Costas and all these you know
the strict lens and Canon all these
monsters you're getting compensated for
it right yeah no I think you know for me
it's again about surrounding myself with
a good team I let my management take
care of all that stuff you know I'm not
gonna uh I trust them and I also you
know work closely with Mike Brown Dan
Lambert American top team those guys are
they know what they're advising me
they've been in the sport from the jump
so like I just have really good people
around me I take care of what I need to
take care of as far as you know just
getting better at fighting and then I
trust them with with the matchups and
stuff and like yeah I want Hamza am I
going to get homs on my next fight like
no like he's fighting for the title soon
right or he's gonna he's gonna be
fighting guys like that but but at the
end of the day like I see myself
fighting him
in a year two years down the road like
that's that's happening 100 that's the
fight I want and that's
um
I hope he's ready for it yeah I'll be
ready yeah yeah
um yeah I just I think it's interesting
you know because again maybe I'm
drinking the the Kool-Aid here but
that's not so far-fetched which I would
never say that usually I'm like dude
this gives out of his mind you know but
I'm like I can see it man I think you
know for I think another reason that
people kind of see me like if most
people say what I say and and act the
way I act
people are going to jump on them like
crazy and I'm really not getting that
much hate like and I think the reason is
because even the people that like want
to hate on me know like low-key in the
back of their mind they're like damn
like he might do it like he might do
that so like I don't really want to hate
too much because they they have nothing
to fall back on right well this one
fight which fight which one are you
talking about you're talking about the
three professional fights that lasted
two minutes in trouble or whatever it is
yeah like what are you gonna what are
you gonna harp on
that doesn't work yeah you know and I
what makes me uh excited is you know I
have a lot of friends in the sport and
nothing to me is more exciting when I
hear about the training room Wars yeah
so when I knew you were getting into it
you know I've contacted ATT I'm like how
is he the real deal because I followed
the restaurant this gets the real deal
like dude you haven't seen [ __ ] you
haven't seen anything yeah like the way
this kid moves and they're telling me
I'm like really like telling us anything
the only time that the only really the
other I'd say two other guys that I've
heard that about was that AK when khabib
first started uh me and DC would train
together and come and do foxy I mean DC
and like this kid could be dude this
kid's on reel and then uh
um oh yeah they they they're like I'm
telling you right this Macho he's he's
like khabib but with better striking and
his wrestling's just as good his his
submission game is different like he's
just a different version could be right
and like the the train room stories that
I hear yeah dude I love them I mean I
the hom thought stories that I hear you
know these crazy ass stories I just love
I love training in campena anytime so
like for me going in and training is
like it's like a little taste of you
know the competition and so that's fun
and I love I love doing that and it's
kind of funny like I go
pretty much anywhere I go if I go to a
gym or whatever like it started off in
college like I'd roll up to like a Jiu
Jitsu gym like maybe I'm doing a clinic
somewhere and they're like yo come roll
and like it'll just be 20 guys rotating
on me yeah and like nobody's teaching me
anything like that's how I started doing
Jujitsu just like all like I would start
with their white belt and then blue belt
then purple then all of a sudden I'd be
rolling the instructor yeah that's how
it would go and uh yeah I'm sure like by
the time my career is over like I'm just
always down to scrap so I'm doing this
at different places and the ATT
there's just so many killers there so
many amazing dudes that I get to work
out with so I'm sure there'll be a lot
of a lot of fun stories to look back on
yeah I can't wait yeah stories well
um now because of the hurricane your
flight got delayed which doesn't make
sense because it's Vegas right but
that's at the airlines for you right so
we had a food truck here and the guy was
like dude I gotta be somewhere else we
only have me for four hours like be cool
man you do grilled cheese right yeah and
then he's like no seriously I get going
so I gotta go so I couldn't have fly you
all the way here after all the hassle it
took for you to get here and give you
cold grilled cheese so my boy Mark's
probably gonna eat all of them so we had
uh my my boy might come out he's the
best griller we know that's gonna put
you some steaks oh yeah and now are you
on a a pretty strict diet so normally I
am I work with training lab with uh Sam
calavita so I'm on point with it but uh
he told me after this fight he's like
let's take a week off so I'm ready to
enjoy yourself all right good it's just
there's steaks and they're delicious
steaks so it's not going to put too much
weight on you now as far as the uh the
UFC career goes this has always been the
goal yeah yeah and did it get faster now
tell me if I'm just off on this and I
mean no kids say this but you because
you're the one who went through this I
would say heartbreak not making the
Olympics yeah which I think was a
blessing yep yeah I think so I'm
grateful for it at this point you know
it's obviously hard anytime you kind of
you know give up a goal and you know I
wanted to win the Olympics from a very
young age and so
um but my plan has always been to do MMA
so like really in 2019 I signed with
first round management like straight out
of college and I was like yo I'm
fighting after the Olympics like and uh
my manager was like
you uh are you gonna continue to wrestle
do you want to get amateur fights this
and that I'm like no I'm not getting any
amateur fights I'm just wrestling and
I'm gonna do the Olympics in 2020 and uh
that but then after that like I'm
fighting like that was the plan it got
pushed back a year because of covid yeah
and I still um
just he asked me again he's like yo you
want to take an amateur fight in the
meantime this and that I was like nope
I'm all on wrestling I'm gonna go all in
on wrestling and you know do whatever I
can to make the team here so were you in
Colorado Springs training no it's
actually College okay yeah yeah so we we
just we still have like probably 15 or
so uh like post Collegiate guys that
train to make the worlds and stuff like
that and uh so I just trained full time
and obviously it didn't work out for me
but the plan was to fight after that and
uh I don't know if it's a sore subject
Why didn't it work out and now granted I
know a little bit Yeah you Saloon to the
fan too right yeah the guy that you lost
to went on to do the damn thing it's not
like you lost some Average Joe this
guy's a [ __ ] stunt yeah so I I took
second of the trials lost to David
Taylor who's my teammate one of my main
training Partners I work out with him
all the time still work out with him to
this day and you know he went on to win
the win the gold medal and uh just won
the World Championships again so it's
won three World titles Olympic gold
medal so yeah I lost a pretty good dude
and I think you know it was that it was
was that it was that 97 86 86 86 kilos
so I I felt like as far as my wrestling
career goes
um
I did what I needed to do and I felt
comfortable like retiring from that
sport you're content I was just more
passionate about MMA at that point I was
content with it yeah because
I just knew I did everything I could do
to achieve my goals and I wanted to move
on to this like new Arena that's just
way more exciting to me and it was hard
because I poured my heart and soul out
into the sport but I also knew like this
is just where I'm this is what I'm more
passionate about and how did with the
loss I mean I'm sure you know as a kid
your goal is to be the gold medalist
when that didn't happen how'd you take
it it was tough how do you deal with
losses you know how she fired back and
yeah okay but you know I I think that uh
it took me a little time to process
um just because it was a hard loss and I
felt like I felt like I was the guy I
felt like it was my time and stuff and I
was ready to ready to do what I needed
to do but you know it just it didn't
work out for me
um and I think
for me I have a very strong faith and I
know God has a plan for me and I think
yeah I think having things happen for a
reason yeah exactly I think and it puts
a chip on your shoulder and I think for
a guy like you who's an ultimate winner
there's like the I'm considering a very
ultimate winner do what you've done
there's like the Kobe Bryants of the
world there's the Tom Brady's there's
something about you guys that you have
this this this
uncurable sensation to to win and from
five years old just dominating like you
have in Penn State dominating you know
national champion and then for you to
fail at this it's going to prepare you
for what you're doing now I 100 feel
that because you know because it can't
be all yeah they're like too far yeah no
he's a
yeah yeah because
um you know it can't be all rainbows and
freaking gold medals you know so it
might be good for you to deal with it
then to get you ready for what you're
about to embark on now in the UFC yeah
on to bigger and better you know and I
think uh
I look back at my wrestling career as a
whole and uh
I didn't really ever achieve my goals
because
going into college like I want to win
four national titles like I won three
which is great it's cool loser just
kidding yeah that's how I feel though
for real a little bit yeah I'm like
I don't really see what I wanted to
achieve so high goals my man that's why
you're at where you're at now uh when
you when you did lose in the Olympics
like when you have a failure like that
because you don't have many
did you you know how would you do were
you depressed what were you talking
about here well you know you don't I
assume you don't drink no that's stupid
no but I uh so I'll to kind of like tell
that story I'll go back to like my
freshman year losing the National Finals
so I took a second my freshman year in
the national finals and after I lost
that match super depressed like really
months like I was like I couldn't think
about anything other than that like I
would wake up or I would have nightmares
about losing and the worst part was like
I have dreams where I won and I would
wake up and realize like I didn't win I
lost and it would be like devastating
yeah nothing worse no I was so bad and
so
um that really that loss coming back
winning the next year taught me a lot
because
both feelings kind of faded away right
like I lost you know a year later I got
another chance I won and uh by the five
six days after I won I was like oh like
I don't really feel like saying that
high anymore it's just like on to the
next yep and then that really was like
wow okay I changed my whole mindset on
how I approached winning and losing and
so you know with all that that helped me
mature a lot and so the Olympic trial is
losing there
I think I handled it well because I
really didn't
value my Performance Based on the win
and loss I valued it based on doing
everything I could do to be the best
Give Me Your Best Shot yeah and I think
you know I hate to like I'm not this
dude but like so going into I didn't
train like pretty much that whole year
to go into the trials because of
injuries and stuff and then two weeks
before the Olympic trials I tore my MCL
like 80 percent it's not good it was
like 10 days before it's not ideal so I
like was just whatever like let's send
it and uh then my first round match I
scratched my cornea it's like I'm just
dealing with like so much stuff and uh
to do what I did and make the final and
you know loose to the best guy in the
world probably the pound like maybe the
pound for pound best guy in the world
like I was like wow like I did
everything I could do and it still broke
my heart I bet I was still devastated
and it was really tough it took me you
know probably a month to where I like
kind of got past it like you're able to
deal with it yeah yeah and I was able to
deal with it and I was also just like
not doing anything like rehabbing
because my knee was messed up and uh
makes it way worse yeah it makes it way
worse but then I was like all right like
let's get into this MMA yeah stuff and I
kind of you know had a new thing to
pursue and I think just like that
maturity from you know handling the loss
my freshman year to handling that loss
uh no one like it doesn't Define me I
really feel like moving forward into
into MMA like a lot of motivation
because if I had maybe done those things
like become a four-time national champ
maybe I wouldn't have pursued the the
Olympics Tom said you want that chip on
your yeah
I feel fine
yeah I'm saying yeah you know you see
some guys that
do everything so young and then it's
like they kind of lose that fire or that
motivation and like I don't want to be
that guy I want to be the dude that's
like you know on the up and up at all
times how'd your pops take the Olympic
loss it was probably tougher for him
than me it's usually tougher in the
family yeah it was tougher for him than
me for sure just because
it's like you know it's your son and he
just pours poured his whole life into me
just to help me you know do what he
could but and he he probably thinks you
know you're dealing with way worse than
you are you know you can't
it's tougher on the family yeah he just
loves me so you know he wants me really
happy and and achieve my goals he knows
how hard I work because he's the one
that's been there from the beginning but
uh and was he uh is he is he a fan that
you're getting to UFC yeah he loves it
does he yeah he loves it my mom loves it
too actually my mom boxed a little bit
yeah I looked I was looking into your
mom box huh yeah so she did like I don't
remember exactly like four or five
amateur fights Jesus Christ yeah so I
mean she it was actually crazy tough
lady yeah I watched uh I only went to
one of her fights and basically like my
mom started boxing mad late like she was
like
had four kids she was like 37 like 3.4
yeah I have three younger sisters oh wow
and so it was like me my younger sisters
we rolled up to this uh Indian Casino in
New Mexico and how old are you I was
like
sixth grade maybe seventh grade it's in
10th for a sixth grade yeah it was like
just me and uh like
my mom they were setting my mom up to
like get whooped by this chick she was
like this 24 year old Golden Gloves
champ like making it into her like like
debut or something and uh
so my mom's just there and I'm just like
sitting in her corner and
um I just she like literally no
cornerman like me and she she rolls in
the ring and this chick's like bouncing
around and stuff and my mom's kind of
just moving with her and uh my mom by
the end of the first round like had like
landed a few good shots the second round
my mom like dropped her put her down got
up and then the third round my mom like
dropped her again they called the fight
damn yeah and she like smashed this
chick that uh one Golden Gloves yeah
your mom's about your family's badass
yeah yeah it makes sense and so like
that after that I mean she wasn't gonna
pursue it like
as a profession she's a PE teacher and
stuff and Coach coach basketball teacher
in the world yeah yeah and uh so you
know that after that she kind of was
like she had she had an injury too she
just wanted to just kind of something to
do yeah she just loves it like love
sports she played college basketball and
stuff and just loved competing so yeah
then uh was your dad like doing well I'm
like a box with four kids so I know I'm
gonna go boxes Casino
she's like my mom and dad stay here with
the kid she's like no they're coming
yeah matter of fact Bo's cornering me
yeah so that's that's like literally if
you meet my mom all the stuff that I'm
saying like makes sense because that's
just like the type of person she is
that's like nuts and I think I kind of I
kind of have a little bit of a little
bit of that too just that fire that yeah
you'd have to yeah yeah let's take a
little break fam for chatting with the
biggest Prospect in the UFC history
talking about Bo nickel because you're
probably watch us right now go these
boys are flowing they're talking all
right man I can't believe it is that
Elon Musk and Jordan Peterson it's not
I'm gonna let you guys in on a little
secret Ron alphabray well really I'm on
alphabet I don't think he is he's just a
high function human being but I need
help that's why I use Alpha Brain we're
talking about the Ultra Premium
nootropic from my friends at on it you
get 10 off when you go to onnit.com
FTD all right onnit.com FTD you get 10
off the greatest nootropic on the planet
we're talking about Alpha Brain if you
don't want to get online you can go to
your local Walmart but nobody wants to
go to Walmart really right unless you
have to pick up like Christmas trees or
pants but get your Alpha Brain for me at
onnit.com FTD you save 10 off Alpha
Brain is the ultimate supplement you
want to get in that flow state with two
little pills we've got you covered if
you don't trust that you're like well
I'm gonna try it and you're not buying
the hype well you you're an outcast
because it works but if you don't all
good man keep it you get your money back
no return necessary that's how confident
on it is of their Alpha Brain so if you
want to try Alpha Brain you've heard all
the hype on it it's the real deal
Holyfield go to onit.com FTD
to receive 10 off your Alpha Brain you
have no reason not to try it because if
you don't like it
get your money back booyah audit.com FTD
alphabray get you some last ad then he
has me watching your favorite show your
favorite food truck with the man the
myth the legend bow nickel
because listen kids I'm here to tell you
about Kratom that's right I'm sitting
down with you staring into this camera
talking about Kratom it's the wild west
out there you don't know if we can trust
it we're gonna get it is it good oh but
I don't like it in the pill form oh I
don't like taking droplets well my
friends that happy hippo they offer all
sorts of various ways to get that pure
delicious Kratom nectar into your body
yep they got gels they got shots gummies
they got all pills if you do if you do
want that we got it all man the powders
you can mix in whatever shake you want
they got it all you have no excuse not
to try the best Kratom on the planet all
right and we talk about happy hippo it's
the only Kratom that I trust this Kratom
is fantastic all right and whatever form
you want to tried in they got you
covered delicious flavors I like the
pink lemonade shot I just take it right
before any show Booyah you boys fired up
ready to go ready to get his Jordan
Peterson on thank thanks to Kratom baby
it's the best focused product I've ever
used and here's what I'm gonna do for
you guys should I do it okay I'll do it
if you guys want 20 off for life all you
got to do is visit happyhippo
herbals.com use promo code thick boy you
get 20 off for life you can use that
code as many times you want share with
your friends share with your mom share
with your gay Aunt I don't care they can
use it that's Happy Hippo herbals.com
promo codes thick boy 20 off Ford life
use as much as you want you're welcome
welcome to the Kratom world the only
world all right you guys are gonna love
it now let's get back to Bow nickel I
think to you know you're talking about
the the Olympic loss and stuff like that
and bouncing back from that and put a
chip on your shoulder it's like we're
not you know as a kid I always thought
the NFL was like Willy Wonka's Chocolate
fact I thought it's gonna be this
amazing place all all you need to do is
get there my life's gonna be set then I
get there and it wasn't that it wasn't
what I thought right
you know I get caught and I I was okay
with it I realized literally in the
middle of camp like oh I might be able
to like bounce around for a few years on
like the practice squad might get up
make might make the 53-man roster but
I'm not going to be you know Gronkowski
or Tony Gonzalez like this is going to
be a four or five year plan right I'll
make a little bit of money but it's not
like I was thinking you know I'm be
Junior Seau or somebody like that yeah
once I realized that I was like I'm okay
with that it's all good this is good but
going back to the way your family digs
harder I told my dad when I went to
Buffalo I was like Dad I wasn't drafted
like the chance of me making it not good
dad they're bringing me as a body and
he's like no I know I know trust me at
the airport I'm like don't get too
excited man I'm gonna do my best but
it's a tough go he's like yeah I know I
know he doesn't know I get cut I didn't
tell him I flew back and there's a
Buffalo Bills flag outside the house
flapping the wind he answers the door
with Buffalo Bills coffee mug ah yeah
man he took it pretty hard that's tough
pretty hard yeah summer so the family
and friends always take it way harder
because I think coming up in sports like
you're not I mean that's how it goes man
sometimes you know sometimes the the
ball doesn't roll your way man I don't
know that much better than my my dad did
right yeah I think you know on the kind
of the same train of thought I was
thinking about this yesterday because
I'm fresh off this win like it was what
less than whatever 24 hours ago and uh I
roll through like with a squad like my
you get a squad here yeah I got a squad
so like this is just like one-fourth of
like my people my whole and it's all
people from like
back in the day like before I even
fought so
um
kind of you know thinking about like
lines like my family so like my wife was
there her parents my parents my sister
they were all there last night yeah a
bunch of my other friends like we had a
ton a ton of people and I realized I was
like wow like I'm so happy that I won
because I get to like see how happy it
makes them like if I just was by myself
and I wanted to be like oh cool but like
seeing them I was like oh that's so much
better so much better because they're
just so happy and having a good time
everybody's together vibing and it was
like
the same way like you know they almost
take it harder it was like
even better though because on the other
side yeah I think too I went I was
watching a fight last night so we have a
policy here now where when we book
Fighters we don't book them after the
fight right so we had uh Anthony Smith
who was scheduled to come on and then uh
he fought this Russian monster and like
his ankle blew out and he was like I'm
so sorry man I gotta cancel the flight I
have to have surgery on my ankle where
I'm like you want to make it and we're
like oh [ __ ] we're all set up to go
and so when they asked for you to come
on they're like it's his fight and my
team's like he fights the day before
welcome we're good we're good we're good
yeah go and buck them like you sure he's
the one guy we're good I was thinking
about that too I was like
I better win this freaking fight I I
like what am I gonna do
I wouldn't be here man yeah I was like I
was like we're like oh the hurricane
actually hit Calabasas dude we have to
cancel sorry bro the man's just like
except the hurricane hit Kell that don't
make sense like I will figure it out but
uh yeah and I was thinking about this
too last night like
the kid that you fought like you know
obviously you made him look like an
amateur but he's not you know what I'm
saying so what sucks for that kid is his
ticket to the chocolate Willy Wonka's
chocolate factory yeah had to go through
a guy named Bo nickel yeah so out of all
the [ __ ] got you know what I'm saying
it's like that was his shot man and he
just you know and he's seven and one
he's had some success right and then
he's like yeah I'm getting the UFC and
then the build up to it obviously has to
say some stuff he's like I know he
thinks he's a badass but I'm gonna put
these hands on him I was like this guy
my guy's watching my girl I'm like baby
you gotta watch this guy has no [ __ ]
clue what he's about to get into this
can be fantastic she's like he seems
pretty tough I'm like doesn't he watch
this doesn't he have you ever seen uh
that movie uh truth or dare yeah this
hormone the guy looks identical there
are people that smile creepy smile bro
he's the truth or dare guy and my
staff's gonna bring it up now side by
side they look identical and that's no
shade only guy I know he's coming off a
loss but the thing is is people just
like my girl she's like oh this guy's
good I'm like you you understand you
know I know that guy's seven and one you
know you talk to your game he's throwing
you know hand and sweaty on the back you
gotta watch this she's like Manny seems
pretty into it I'm like no he thinks
he's going to win that's the best part
that's the best part he thinks this can
go well for him but can you imagine like
just the [ __ ] luck of the draw sorry to
cuss I can't stop cussing do I try I
have kids they cuss it's all good bro
but the the just the luck of the draw
the guy finally gets his shot you know
his agent's like dude I got you an
opportunity Contender so he's like Kelly
that's go time he's telling he has an
Entourage yeah he's like here we go boys
his family's there and like whom I find
like Bo Nick was like [ __ ] you know but
in his head he's like yeah let's do this
man and now he's back to the drawing
board it's a little freaked up like out
of all the guys like
because legit I was like you know for
and I was telling Laura Sanchez I'm like
these guys they're not getting
opportunity like but there's nobody can
come through it's going to be about so
just [ __ ] move him on or keep him
there and just [ __ ] people over but let
him go to the UFC and have those like
that guy should be back next week give
him another opportunity I felt I did
feel bad for him because I'm sure he's a
nice guy I'm sure he works hard and uh
you know puts a lot of effort into it
like I respect anybody that comes in the
cage I I feel like a little bit I'm like
really bro you saw you signed the fight
like you're a little nuts like what are
you doing that was my thing I'd be like
a freaking injury yeah right now say you
got monkey box I was nervous that's real
popping right now but I got monkey pox
man [ __ ] just give me another opponent
it's yeah I don't
I don't know how they get these guys to
agree to fight me it's kind of crazy but
um especially at this level I guess you
know if you're in his position you're
thinking
oh I'm I'm seven and one I fought real
Fighters like the guy he beat last like
was a high level high level wrestler
like you know Pennsylvania guy like did
did well division one wrestling no
Progressive division one but the guy was
like Philly dude like good wrestler
for MMA yeah and so I think you know
that's why he's like oh like I can do
this I'm confident this guy has two
flights like he might not be able to
this game there's wrestlers right yeah
yeah and then and then I'm like
I was talking with Mike you know before
the fight Mike Brown I was like
what what's this guy doing like why is
he fighting me this and that and he was
like
I don't know it's it's I think it's also
like I have a minute like now I guess
two minutes of film footage so like
people don't really know they don't know
yeah they don't know ignorance is bliss
yeah he's like no I can win this his
team's like
yeah yeah no doubt man have fun you got
it bro yeah you got this man just just
don't get taken down yeah I think it's
socked in the face and dropped and like
[ __ ]
yeah I I think genuinely though like
people don't really know who they're
dealing with like with me and and why
would they like I'm I barely have any
fights and there's not really like any
footage of me like it's not like I'm Jon
Jones with 20 fights and all these
finishes that people are like studying
like I pretty much every single fight I
fought has been like a minute or less so
and then it's always going to be the
excuse oh he fought the he fought a can
like of course he did that to him it's
like well I did it to a real dude that
trains so that's seven and one yeah yeah
he you know he's had aspirations to get
to the UFC mm-hmm
so we'll see again when you get to the
which you're in the UFC now dude you're
on the freaking UFC video game that's
pretty dope
yeah I wasn't really I wasn't really
sure how that was gonna go I saw I was
dominating the uh what do you call it
the voter of the voting thing and then
they gave me the uh Laura gave me the
little uh video game with me on the
cover and I was like oh that's sick but
of course you're they're like we'll see
out of these four who's winning the game
I was like right there
they're probably going to violate me
they're going to be like striking 52 Jiu
Jitsu 68 wrestling 99 yeah yeah yeah
yeah I'm like Matt Hughes and yeah UFC
seven yeah just horrible ratings you
know but uh you know it's it's coming
fast you know do you feel that way
faster than I expected so I'll I'll say
like kind of how it happened from my
perspective how does that stake though
real quickly too like a big Mike yeah
he's the head of thick boy over there
you're the man thank you appreciate it
yeah I never trust a skinny Chef my man
nice no never
I uh so
so from my perspective before any of
this happened when I had two amateur
fights and I was making my Pro debut
um I was thinking I was gonna have five
or six Pro fights and then the UFC was
gonna be like all right like it's
usually how it goes yeah like uh you
know maybe we'll put you on this this
show and see if you do well and then
maybe we'll bring you on and so that's
kind of what I was assuming was going to
happen
so my first pro fight we go on uh it's
on Mosby dolls promotion on icon and
um I'm finding a dude first off he's an
Ono Pro as well has like a I don't know
he has like 10 or 12 amateur fights and
like 20 amateur boxing fights so a lot
more experience than me yeah he's not
like a killer by any means he's like a
500 record dude but he has 30 fights
between you know two different sports
his experience yeah and he called me out
oh and so we fought on the same amateur
show and uh he was like I want Bo nickel
let's go let's run it and those are
great yeah I was like okay
I'm like let's go yeah and uh so
fight gets signed he makes it to the
cage knock him out in 30 seconds cold on
his feet and uh immediately
like people are going nuts like just
loving it so this was on icon on UFC
Fight Pass yep so obviously the UFC gets
all the numbers they know how everything
does and uh
long story short by that was like a
Saturday it was a fight on Saturday by
Sunday morning I had done like the
second most views ever on UFC Fight Pass
history it makes sense I watched it and
then uh and I don't watch anything right
and then the number one show was the
milk boys did a show like they did a
fight
um like a card or something yeah and and
then by the second day because they'd go
based on a week of ratings and by the
second day I passed them up damn so I
did the number one yeah I did people
want to see me so at that point like the
next morning so the Saturday night fight
Sunday morning UFC's calling bellator's
calling uh pfl I'd already been talking
with them one FC made me an offer every
organization was like let's go let's run
it and I was like
I'm a freaking I'm a UFC guy like I'm
not a I respect the other organizations
tons of great Fighters all over the
place now especially nowadays but it's
not just not and that's where I'm that's
what I am people argue with me all the
time about it and you know UFC through
and through you you see uh alumni it's
just a different you know if if you the
the guy in the CFL who won you know Mbps
CFL is not call himself the best
quarterback in the world right come on
bro yeah you know it's Aaron Rodgers Tom
Brady if you're not playing the NFL yeah
you might you might be really good but
if I haven't seen you go against you
know the Denver Broncos defense and the
top tier guys I can't call you the best
in the world man that's how I felt and I
was like I'm just it's not on brand with
me to do anything other than be in the
UFC and so immediately we're talking
with them figuring out what we can do
and uh they're like you know you want to
know like you need some fights and then
they're like well Contender series
coming up let's let's get you on
Contender series see how it goes and
then it went so man did it go and I
think now at Frank mirin yesterday when
I talked talking about you and frankly
who beat them that's Frank Mayer knows
the thing or two about fighting this who
beat somebody who are you gonna bet you
know dude you barking up the wrong tree
here my man I'll convince you you know
he'll be freaking France and Ghana right
now but uh he uh he he we were talking
about uh managing young Fighters and I
don't know how it went down you know
with the contender series maybe even
with your experience you know when I was
fighting there was no uh Dana White
Contender series there was The Ultimate
Fighter which at the time was the
biggest deal not you know if you did
well on that show you'd get a contract
in the UFC but now it seems like
The Ultimate Fighter is not not what it
used to be people are really tuning in
it's on ESPN plus I don't I couldn't
tell you last 10 seasons who comes off
there it's just not the move anymore you
know nobody's watch it's like the real
world mixed with fighting right but now
if I had a fighter Contender series all
day yeah like that you know you think
about the sugar Shawn came out of there
uh Jamal Hill like there's some Savages
that come out of there now for sure like
it's kind of taken over from what The
Ultimate Fighter used to be I think
you've really helped out with that where
you know these huge stars and your star
coming in which I think helps the show
definitely I I think like
I was happy to do Contender series
because gaming fights quick like I don't
have to think about and do all this
stuff and everybody wants that like it
made it easier for me to get fights
because people want that shot yeah it
just sucks like it sucks but a guy's
gonna be like is the guy gonna say no to
a chance to fight in the UFC like and
probably get paid you know
Contender series fights not crazy but
it's more than they're getting paid on a
regionals anymore and you're on national
TV yeah it's a big opportunity right so
like I think you know the show worked
well for
the UFC for for me
um and and kind of you know obviously
not my opponents but
just the fact that I got to compete a
lot a lot in a quick time span and you
get exposure get exposure like a lot of
people are wanting to watch me now I
gotta I got a good amount of hype I
don't build up for my next fight
and then you know we did crazy numbers
on that and I I mean obviously there's
other good Fighters that were on this
season that card last night was good
for sure I just like to like oh let's go
to the polls see who's gonna be on the
the video game cover I was like really
and then obviously they knew you were
going to win so the cover's ready to go
yeah it just popped I'd be like how long
I'm gonna pretend that you didn't win
this but um yeah I think the contender
series good for that it's it's uh it's I
would say it's probably the best way to
get into the UFC because it kind of
built it has their own audience it's a
good way to get in it's not like you
have to spend whatever three months in a
house I don't know how long Ultimate
Fighter is six weeks you have to spend
six weeks in the house like I don't
really want to do that no it sucked but
uh I'm down to do Contender series and
it's it's a big it's a lot bigger
platform than any Regional promotion oh
for sure way bigger yeah for sure uh so
for you I would I would figure they're
going to fight you pretty soon because
they want to you know
kind of roll with the with the hype
that's going on and people are paying
attention attention to you yeah you know
and Dana did and I I agree with him I
think it's good you know there's no easy
fights in the UFC there's no easy fights
but again you can't have a guy who you
know again who eight and one or nine and
one maybe he won Contender before you or
after you whatever and they put him in
there his first fight to you like again
it's [ __ ] these guys over yeah so
with you I'm curious what they're going
to do with you you know what I'm saying
so it's like what what I would do if I
you know I was your manager and right
notes I don't care but if uh they have
that big matte Square Garden card
people seen you fight there before
wrestle there before put you on that
thing I would have you kick off the
Pay-Per-View yeah I mean I'm definitely
down to do that I'll
I'll do a main card whatever I'm ready
to fight so because I get going slow I'm
all about yeah
I would and there's some MMA heads in
here so George the big MMA head Casey
Mark there's MMA head down there George
name the last time there's like a
prospect of this caliber like I'd say
Aaron Pico's close but he doesn't have
your same background he went to Bellator
and he also started at 19 right like
yeah he's 26. yeah he was very young
yeah very young yeah
so but I just think it's not I think
you're ready for it you know what I'm
saying that I think you know in Pico
allude to this he's like that's what he
said he goes you look at DC who went
straight from the Olympics and you know
wrestling straight into the the big
shows you know on strike force in the
UFC but he was 31 or something like that
he was he was mentally ready for he goes
I was 19 dude I was not ready to kick
off mask Square Garden also against a
guy who's nine in one who was a former
LFA Champions like he was way too much
for me well yeah there would be no like
if I was 18 19 right now and hadn't had
all the life experience that I do
we're not even having this conversation
like you know that's that's a very
different place than you know where I'm
at right now 26 I've competed all over
the world I've competed in sold out
Arenas regularly I had you know 120 plus
College matches that were all high
pressure yep and uh competed in the
Olympic trials that type of thing feel
very mature very like
you know getting to the point where I'm
like
going to be in my physical prime here in
probably like you know three four five
years and uh yeah everything's kind of
like on the up and up I think like where
I'm at mentally where I'm at physically
is kind of like aligning to like you
know Peak here relatively soon yeah
you're only gonna get better yeah yeah
it's the scary thing yeah definitely I
have a lot of I mean and I've only been
doing MMA for one one year it's insane
yeah and I think too what was uh
institutos to you is when you won your
second fight on the downstairs I'm like
they gotta sign now this is on and Dana
was like we want to do one more fight
get some more experience and you could
have been like you know the camera's
right I didn't get them like God you
wouldn't say goddamn but you'd be like
oh cheese and rice or whatever you say
you know uh but you were like yeah cool
man son of a biscuit yeah they're scared
away you know something nerdy but uh but
you did it you were like cool
you're cool with it I don't care yeah
I'm I know what I'm going like I said
this in interview before but
my goal isn't to you know be in the UFC
or fight in the UFC or be UFC fighter
like it's not going to be UFC champ like
I want to be the powerful number one guy
on the planet yes so when he said yeah
like you know let's get him another
fight like that doesn't change my
trajectory or plan at all like I was
happy about it because Batman I don't
really have to worry so much about like
setting up a whole nother fight
or like I just have to like they're
gonna take care of it and I gotta fight
in six weeks like this is great so for
me
it was awesome and again at that point
I'm 2-0 like I want more fights I want
to fight before I fight for the title
like 10 12 times if I can yeah and I
mean we'll see if that can if that
actually happens probably not dude yeah
you win you and four were going really
Sizzler yeah so that's like kind of
where I'm at is like
you know I know what where I want to be
I know my goals and I'm going to do what
I need to do to align with that the
other stuff's going to take care of
itself and
yeah I want experience I just love
fighting too it's fun yeah I can tell I
think you're gonna do it my man I would
say I said if you're a stock man I'd be
all in you know no doubt I appreciate
that yeah man I've been a fan for a long
time we've watched you on the show and
then yeah right after your your second
fight and they're like oh he's fighting
soon so let's do it after that that's
when team's like oh we don't I think
they told you like yeah we don't do guys
after fights they can't be like we're
good
we're good for sure so I appreciate you
brother
um I'm so excited for you man like
you're just getting started your
Energy's as dope as I thought it was
gonna be you got this cool confidence
like demeanor about you you come from a
good family he's a Colorado boy
Rifle Colorado in the sticks with horses
you're out there dude there's not a lot
going on out there for you but I'm sure
they'll put up a statue in Rifle
Colorado which are all over man but I
can't thank you enough for coming on me
I know it's been a long day for you
hopefully the stakes uh you know were
good enough because can I give you cold
uh grilled cheese man but uh I'm just so
excited for you man you make my life
more exciting watching fight and
watching it come up there's nothing
better when someone's come through the
rankings and you're doing the damn thing
man so good luck brother appreciate it
you got this you're the best
and before we leave oh man I have a
splash of CT and forgot I have to do
this
so for uh for food truck my boys suplex
in Philly which isn't too far from you
how far is Philly from you about like
three hours man okay farther than I
thought okay short short uh plane
um so my boys at suplex Philly I always
you know I'm a sneaker huge sneaker guy
of course you came with hot sneakers
yeah yeah I will say this I was
surprised with your fashion you got a
dope screenshot the dope ass uh just
George there and the thing is is most
wrestlers and one of my best friends at
least they're bowling he's like Mr
Colorado wrestling you know
um most wrestlers have awful fashion
times they come in with the worst
fashion of all time they just don't give
a [ __ ] they just want to break people
and pin them and [ __ ] yeah so they don't
care about fashion so when we were
picking shoes for you I was like oh man
the dress is pretty swag if you don't
want to go too like you don't want to
give them like some yellow Yeezys or
somebody's never going to wear so my
boys in uh suplex family so I said you
know they're they're Penn State colors I
think they're not too crazy I love it
dunks are classic like they're legendary
you're a legend in the making my man
you're a legend of Penn State but I
think you're going to make your mark in
the UFC and this is for my boys and
Philly said please wear enjoy these Penn
State dunks big fans here let the shop
come by if you're ever in Philly suplex
beautiful thank you so much yeah man so
hopefully you rock those hopefully not
too swaggy you got some swag for you
dude thank you dude appreciate you bro
you're the best man thank you if you're
into thick boys
like subscribe comment
and God bless America well that's not my
big one just kidding